tonight the clark county school district
board of trustees will talk about the
process of hiring an interim
superintendent now this comes a week
after dr jarrah was fired from his job
kate houston live in studio now to
explain the process of actually filling
that role full time and also what our
next steps might be kate yes dr jarrah
is the first superintendent in ccsd
history to be fired from his position
the process of hiring a superintendent
can take months and even quite a bit of
money local unions want the board to
come together to focus on the task at
hand there have been three different
superintendents over the past 10 years
the search time ranged from two to eight
months consisting of board meetings
parent town halls and recruiters
executives search firms were used for
two out of the three hires jarrah and
dwight jones costing around 50 thousand
dollars each time one superintendent pat
skorkowski was hired locally the
teachers and administrators union says
it's time for some stability and
priorities to shift or the process needs
to be done correctly it needs to be
transparent we need to ensure that
you know the students are again a top
priority staff and the community deserve
that i think that's really important
that we have a superintendent who comes
in and
reestablishes relationships and trusts
with staff as the search starts
administrators union deputy executive
director jeff horn hopes the board will
heavily consider local candidates
the timeline to fill the position full
time remains to be seen tonight the
board will discuss hiring an interim
superintendent both unions want this
process to be done efficiently since dr
jarrah has less than a month left at
ccsd